a political panel for thursday uh
delighted to welcome for the first time
uh gary stevenson former city trader
turned inequality economic i can't even
say economist gary hello
hi jeremy that's poacher turn gamekeeper
isn't it that is let's be honest
uh well they're more similar than you
think in a way
it's a compliment and also better
expense conservative commentator how are
you sir i'm well thank you is that a new
moustache
it is it has been growing it over the
month of november because as many other
young men do well i've tried but
obviously i haven't succeeded but it's a
very good thing november uh fair play to
you we'll start with a big news story of
the day hs2 i think uh we tried very
clearly on this show to make the point
that hs2 has not been scrapped yes it's
been modified the government are still
spending 96
billion pounds
uh interestingly we had john stephenson
the mp for carlila torre mp but not part
of the redwall new intake a man who
represented gary and benedict carlyle
for 11 years and he said
i i'm i'm not disappointed we're
spending money in the north we never did
we're talking about the north like we
never did uh possibly it's boris
spouting off without you know being able
to see it through but it's still a
massive massive investment let's start
with you bet at expense what do you make
of today has he betrayed the north or
not
oh i just think
yes it is a massive investment in the
north but it is still ultimately an
investment that serves london that's the
way you need to look at hs2 you know you
it takes about the same amount of time
to get from london to manchester as it
does to get from liverpool to bradford
you know these are not small cities in
the north of england and it's about half
the distance between liverpool and
bradford or huddersfield and warrington
and places like that these are not small
places they're large they have
potentially very large industrial bases
lots of dead housing stock there that
can be used there is an awful lot of
potential there and actually what they
need is interconnectivity they don't
need greater connectivity with london
yeah ultimately i think that that is the
point that a lot of people in the north
are saying the government is missing so
yes there is investment coming to
manchester uh birmingham isn't in the
north but you know it is getting to
manchester and there will be
improvements to the leeds line but it's
not actually what the north wants or
needs what they need is better
connectivity to get them from point a to
b in the north and i think ultimately
that's the thing that they keep on
saying nobody's listening to us over i
think that's a fascinating response
benedict i mean that gary what's your
take on this pal
well i mean it's fair to say that i
think there'd be some people in bradford
who might disagree about whether we're
leveling up by removing this railing
that was
expected and that was promised and that
people in many northern cities were
hoping to see and you know i think this
um
i think this adds to a move we've been
seeing where the government promises
leveling up but when when we actually
look at the details do we actually get
leveling up i mean in the clovis crisis
billionaire wealth up 22 the average
billionaire wealth increased by 600
million pounds during kobe
ordinary people 2.5 percent extra tax on
your national insurance and now when it
comes to living up north and south
does the north get the railway link that
it was expected
no but it does still get 96 billion
quicker so we have to answer that i i'm
with you the initial response is oh my
god political hot potato he's done it
again
he will describe it
that he's investing 96 billion pounds in
trying to do it in a clever way
benedict's saying actually it's
interconnectivity and i think having
lived in in the north for 15 years i
think he's absolutely right spot on this
obsession with getting to london is not
a massive thing you want to get across
the penins you want to be able to get
you know east and west that's an
absolute fact right i actually
of all the stuff i've heard today
benedict absolutely spot on but the fact
is gary i want i i think you know
the boris haters will jump up and say
he's done it again i just
maybe maybe their argument should be
look politics changes government changes
you you make a promise in a manifesto
and things change i think the message is
yes
some people could assume that he's let
them down but i do think they're still
investing that money don't you
maybe not correctly
96 billion pounds is great you know and
it's better than it spent than not spent
especially after this crisis we're
looking at a long slow recovery if you
look at financial markets we need money
spent to boost the economy 96 billion
pounds is great it should be spent it
should be spent wisely it should be
spent intelligently but the top 250
individuals most rich individuals in
this country made 106 billion pounds
last year 250 individuals okay so that's
more money for the richest 250
individuals in the country during a time
of enormous economic crisis then for the
entire northern railway investment is
that why you stopped me is that why you
stopped being a city trader
oh i didn't make 106 billion pounds i
wish i did you'd still be doing it
wouldn't you you'd still be doing it
fair play
i made enough money do you both believe
separately or whatever um we've talked a
lot about boris johnson and this sort of
teflon existence whereby he seems to be
able to bounce back
sometimes there are moments in a prime
minister's career um
the tory 1922 back bench committee is is
is rather hard-faced and and difficult
he admitted yesterday boris johnson he
felt he crashed the car there are people
saying that this is the beginning of the
end what's your take on that gas
well i mean obviously i've been looking
at this um
this talk about corruption uh it's
it's obviously upsetting when you look
what happened during the copied crisis
the amount of money made by super
wealthy people that in itself is causing
a huge concern my main concern here is
we have a chancellor who is worth an
approximated 200 million pounds
much more than that
three billion
his father-in-law is a billionaire yeah
and we have billionaires that made an
enormous amount management crisis and
when government money is needed
do they tax the billionaires who made an
enormous amount of crisis
no they raised taxes two and a half
percent on ordinary workers my concern
really here is that
so many in the government come from very
wealthy backgrounds that they are not
looking to tax
the super rich and the super rich are
getting richer and richer and richer
while ordinary people having their taxes
raised if that's what happens it's going
to be just like 2008 we're going to have
a super strong recovery for the super
rich and a super weak recovery for the
ordinary working people of this country
benedict what's your take
i mean it's a very interesting point to
raise because actually increasing taxes
on ordinary sort of middle and lower
class middle middle and lower income
workers you know that is now the tory
base that is what the tourists are sort
of meaning to appeal to so actually it's
not it's kind of an important point
especially when you do have a lot of
tour mps in increasingly marginal seat
sources that were only just one from the
labour party those are seats that could
be up at the next general election the
thing for me is boris johnson will have
been very confident throughout this
parliament because ultimately his his
opponent is kierstarma that's the person
that he has to beat on paper
he can do that regardless of there being
a sleaze candle i think there's been
polling out that says even if there were
to be a general election tomorrow he
would still get a majority ultimately
because people just don't trust the
labour party enough well they don't know
what they stand for because he's never
there because he's always got covered
exactly what this is the thing
the fear is that tipping point
not so much about kierstarma it's about
his own backbench mp will enough of them
be concerned enough about their own
seats because they're going to lose
those votes because taxes are going up
on their voters for them to say actually
boris johnson might win the next general
election but i might not be an mp and
therefore it's worth rising up that's
the key point i don't think we're there
yet because i don't think that there is
a candidate yet who has stuck their head
above the parapet enough uh to say yes i
tell you
everybody says that rishi sunak will be
the next leader i actually don't think
he will i think that rishi sunak will be
guilty by association and the and
and political history certainly on the
tory side is littered with the person
that they think is going to get it
michael hesseltein
i don't know look loads of them and
cameron came from nowhere and john major
came from nowhere and whether it's liz
truss or somebody down the pecking order
that's what i genuinely believe will
happen but i also yeah i have to say
benedict i'm with you i think the danger
to boris johnson is himself i think that
if he believes forevermore that he can
get through these things he'll get
bitten on the backside i think he has to
be wiser and smarter final thing guys
today and this is something i talked
about just now uh with with bill
etheridge an ex-mep um government plans
to um say to the migrants who arrive
here in their dingus uh we're gonna send
you to albania within seven days uh
you're gonna stay there in basically uh
an albanian sort of um
i don't know holding pen it's gonna cost
the british taxpayer one hundred
thousand pounds a year per person uh
bill esther jimmy p said i thought we
left the european union to take control
of our borders why don't we just get
boats and send these people back gary
stevenson what's your take you talk
about wanting the people of this country
to be leveled up should we be
taking more people in that we can when
we can't afford our own people or do you
think that we should show a strong arm
of the law and look after our own first
and foremost
of course we need to look after our own
but when i saw we were going to talk
about this i had to look and research
what's going to happen so they're
talking about and
processing center in albania there's
basically only one country that has done
this before which is australia and look
what happened they went from 20 000
immigrants in one year to 160. i'm not
sticking up for it i'm giving you the
facts people will point to that and go
it worked
well if you look what happened the u.n
said that it broke the torture
convention yeah statistics suggest that
it didn't significantly reduce
immigration there were 22 people died in
that center
300 people committed 300 children is
approximately committed self-harm the
international criminal court declared it
illegal and said that physical physical
and sexual violence from the guards was
rife okay look i'm a british person i
don't want to camps up in albania where
we pay and by the way that came in
massively over budget three million
pound per person it cost to have
physical and sexual violence
under the australian flag is that what
you want under the british flag in
albania really because personally look
i believe in this country i think we're
better than that
that's a really interesting point
bennett another great take on it we
hadn't had that already that's a great
take isn't it from gary to be fair well
absolutely absolutely and the other
thing i think is that we have to
remember the australian example is
interesting because australia was the
only country really that those
immigrants were aiming to go for whereas
actually in europe there are many
alternatives that people can go to why
do they oh right this please forgive me
i'm not trying to offend anybody bill
etheridge made a really good point he
said i have sympathy with people uh
leaving war-torn countries but they're
all coming from france why don't they
stay in france well there are lots of
different reasons some of them already
have family here some of them speak
english rather than french you know
there are lots of different reasons why
but actually the key thing here is not
so much that there are lots i'm trying
to come to the uk because there are many
tens of thousands in france there are
hundreds of thousands of immigrants in
germany in the nordic countries in spain
and italy and my thing that i think is
why this is very unlikely is let's say
we strike an agreement with albania how
long is it before germany or denmark or
italy then strike their own deal with
somebody else and another country with
another and then you get it becomes more
of a phenomenon because there are far
more countries that can do it here
whereas if you're just australia and you
have papua new guinea there's just one
opportunity for you to do that and it's
a one-off thing whereas there are quite
literally very many countries in europe
that would like to strike these sorts of
deals and then you will ultimately get a
situation where countries like albania
can begin to sort of as it were take the
highest bids from different countries
yeah and then it becomes a lot more you
know then it becomes a sort of a rush to
the bottom say well how much money will
you offer us rather than these people to
take all of your mindsets it becomes an
auction of humanity absolutely yeah and
it's not what we want ultimately guys i
have to say genuinely love today
fascinating and really really good to
have you both on bennett expense gary
stevenson thank you very much indeed
that was thursday's political panel
anything you want to talk about my
friends as ever your show oh three
double four portable nine one thousand
looking out the window people stand
outside radio studios like this
and you wanna go trying to talk uh three
double four photo one nine one thousand
text two eight seven treble two this is
jk on drive we're here till seven